alright guys so they released a new
spider-man trailer and I'm here to talk
to you about it this trailer gave me an
interesting vibe I'm very curious about
spider-man I feel like this movie could
kind of be the Dark Horse of the summer
because I know a lot of people were
expecting the Avengers to be good a lot
of people are expecting Dark Knight
Rises to be good for me I'm just really
curious about what direction they're
going to go in with this movie once
again this trailer really focuses on
Peter Parker's parents so obviously his
parents are a huge role in this movie
something that the previous films really
didn't talk about very much
it's obviously they're very integral to
the plot we get a lot more hints at the
parents and how his history with his
parents also connects to the lizard in
this movie which is interesting
the CGI looks amazing the colors the
vibrance of the colors in this trailer
are very impressive lots of hints on red
all the red car lights on the street are
really exaggerated his costume is
extremely bright red and it looks really
beautiful I'm very impressed with the
visuals of this trailer also summing
this trailer tells me is that emma stone
gwen stacy has an awareness of who Peter
Parker is spider-man because they're
talking about how her dad is after him
and everything she knows so that's kind
of interesting cuz I would create like a
bigger bond between those two characters
and I like that also you can see
spider-man making jokes now a lot of
fans really want to see if they want to
see spider-man making jokes and being
witty and funny and we definitely get
that in this trailer and I think a lot
of fans are gonna be really pleased with
that I'm pleased with that I can really
see Andrew Garfield in this character
he's really working for me as his
character I really like that we get a
lot of shots of the lizard here he looks
great
my question really was how can they make
him personally involved with this movie
so much so that to connect with Peter
Parker not should be the lizard but it
seems like they're making them connect
with the parents and so that personal
connection will really make the film and
the confrontation better won't just be
like a fight scene it'll be like an
actual emotional confrontation which
will make the film even better also we
get to see Spidey doing some
wall-crawling yes I love wall-crawling
there was way too much swinging in the
other movies I liked the idea of him
crawling up walls more I hoped that get
more of that in this movie a lot more
the only thing I didn't like about this
trailer is that the big ending shot of
the trailer was the same big ending shot
as last time I was hoping that they were
going to maybe show a little bit
something different other than that I'm
impressed with this trailer I'm excited
for this movie I feel like it could
surprise a lot of people but still on
more pump for Dark Knight Rises it's
just because it's Dark Knight Rises you
know but still this movie is looking
very good what do you guys think of the
new trailer let me know below and until
next time guys if you like this review
you can
scribe to my channel and get stuck mine
eyes